UNBELIEVABLE.
BY FIRST, OPPOSITION WITHIN
AND WITHOUT IS THE FOCUS OF
TONIGHT'S ANGLE.
THEY WERE IN THE USUAL
BREAK-OUT MODE AFTER THE
PRESIDENT SPOKE IN
PENNSYLVANIA OVER THE WEEKEND.
WHAT THEY WERE OBSESSING ABOUT
HIS HARSH SLAM ON TODD THEY
MICED THE HEAT.
>> WE PUT ON TARIFFS AND THE
EUROPEAN UNION IS OUT THERE.
YOU CAN'T GO HIGHER THAN YOU
ARE ANYWAY.
THEY HAVE TRADE BARRIERS.
WE CAN'T SELL THE FARMING
GOODS THERE.
THEY RESTRICT US.
THEY SAY WE WANT THE TARIFFS
TAKEN OFF.
GOOD.
OPEN UP THE BARRIERS AND GET
RID OF THE TARIFFS.
IF YOU DON'T DO THAT WE ARE
GOING TO TAX MERCEDES-BENZ,
WE'LL TAX B.M.W.
YOU WANT TO HAVE MONEY?
>> Laura: BACK ON THE
CAMPAIGN TRAIL.
AWESOME!
EVERY SINCE HE SLAMMED HE
WOULD SLAM STEEL AND ALUMINUM
IMPORTS IN THE UNITED STATES
THE REPUBLICANS ON THE HILL
ARE TRYING TO CONVINCE HIM,
MR. PRESIDENT, YOU ARE WRONG.
>> IMPOSING THE STEEL TARIFFS
INTERJECTED UNCERTAINTY IN THE
ECONOMY WHERE IT WASN'T
NECESSARY.
>> WE WILL END UP COSTING MORE
JOBS BECAUSE OF THE TARIFFS
THAN WILL BE SAVED.
>> I DISAGREE WITH THE
PRESIDENT.
>> I DON'T KNOW OF ANY TRADE
WAR THAT ENDS WELL.
THAT IS NOT MY READING OF
HISTORY.
>> WE WANT TO LIMIT THE
COLLATERAL ECONOMIC DAMAGE AS
POSSIBLE.
>> Laura: HOW MANY OF THOSE
GUYS WANT OHIO -- WELL, NOW
THEY ARE THREATENING TO PASS
LEGISLATION TO ESSENTIALLY
NULLIFY THE PRESIDENT'S
EXECUTIVE ORDER.
>> ALL RIGHT.
LET'S HAVE TARIFFS AND COUPLE
IT WITH UNCERTAINTY.
THAT IS WORSE.
TARIFFS ARE AWFUL.
TARIFFS TO UNCERTAINTY IS
PROBABLY WORSE.
>> WE HAVE LEGISLATIVE TOOLS
AT THE DISPOSAL AND HOW DO WE
GET IT TO THE PRESIDENT FOR
THE SIGNATURE?
>> I'M NOT HAPPY WITH IT.
THE TARIFFS ARE GOING TO BE A
TAX ON THE AMERICAN CITIZEN.
>> I THINK THERE IS A GOOD
CHANCE WE WILL NULLIFY THEM.
>> WITH RESPECT TO SENATOR
HATCH YOU SUPPORTED THE T.P.P.
AND YOU WANTED TO EXPAND NASA
AND YOU SUPPORTED GIVING OBAMA
THE FAST TRACK TRADE
AUTHORITY.
HE HAS BEEN WRONG ON EVERY
TRADE RELATED ISSUE IN MY
MIND.
NOW HE AND JEFF FLAKE, BOTH
SOON TO BE RETIREES ARE
SUDDENLY THE SLEDGEHAMMERS
AGAINST TARIFFS.
ONCE AGAIN WE SEE THAT MOST
DON'T GET WHY TRUMP AGAINST
ALL EXPERT PREDICTIONS WON THE
G.O.P. NOMINEE AND THE
PRESIDENCY.
DO MITCH McCONNELL BELIEVE
TRUMP WOULD HAVE WON OHIO AND
WISCONSIN IF HE TOUTED THE
GLOBALIST LINE THAT ALL TRADE
NO MATTER WHAT HAPPENS TO THE
AMERICAN WORKER IS GOOD TRADE?
DO YOU REMEMBER ALL THE ROSY
PREDICTION ABOUT OPENING UP
THE TRADE RELATIONSHIP WITH
CHINA?
FABULOUS.
FREE AND MORE FREE PRESS.
PLEASE.
NO OBJECTIVE REVIEW SINCE WE
APPROVED CHINA INTO THE TRADE
ORGANIZATION WOULD SAY IT'S A
WIN FOR THE U.S.
LAST YEAR WE HAD THE HIGHEST
TRADE DEFICIT ON RECORD WITH
CHINA.
BY THE WAY, CHINA RIPPED OFF
OUR INTELLECTUAL PROPERTY AND
FLOODED THE MARKET WITH EXCESS
CAPACITY OF STEEL AND
ALUMINUM.
YOU CAN SEE THE NUMBERS THERE.
THIS HAS DRIVEN DOWN THE
PRICES WORLDWIDE AND DRIVEN
GREAT U.S. COMPANIES OUT OF
BUSINESS.
THE CHINA COMMUNIST REGIME
ENDS UP DISTORTING THE GLOBAL
MARKETPLACE.
THEY ARE NOT EFFICIENT THE WAY
THEY OPERATE.
THE PRESIDENT REITERATED IN
PENNSYLVANIA LOOK, THEY DON'T
HAVE A HAND ON THE TRADE ISSUE
EITHER.
RIGHT NOW WE ARE RUNNING $150
BILLION TRADE DEFICIT WITH THE
E.U.
THEY PUT UP UNFAIR BARRIERS TO
THE AGRICULTURE PRODUCTS,
MASSIVE SUB DIDTIES TO --
SUBSIDIARIES AND THEY HAVE
BEEN TAKING ADVANTAGE OF THE
UNITED STATES FOR TOO LONG.
FAILING TO MEET MILITARY
OBLIGATION UNDER NATO.
TRUMP FORCED THEIR HAND AND
THE SKY DID NOT FALL.
THEY ARE CONTRIBUTING MORE TO
THE MILITARY.
NOW HE IS DEFENDING THE
U.S. ECONOMIC INTERESTS WITH
THE FAIRLY NARROWLY CAST
ALUMINUM AND STAFF -- STEEL
TARIFFS.
THERE IS HISTORICAL PRECEDENT.
BUCHANAN WROTE IN A COLUMN
LINCOLN TO McKINLEY AND
ROOSEVELT AND COOLIDGE, THE
REPUBLICAN PARTY ERECTED THE
MOST AWESOME MANUFACTURING
MACHINE THE WORLD HAD EVER
SEEN.
THROUGH THE SEVEN DECADES THE
G.O.P. WAS REWARDED BY
BECOMING AMERICA'S PARTY.
TRUMP'S INSTINCT ON TRADE HAVE
BEEN SPOT ON FOR DECADES.
AS CHINA BECOME MORE
REPRESSIVE AND THE U.S. MEDIA
FLATTENED, THE MAINLINE
REPUBLICANS OFFER THE MIDDLE
CLASS MORE OF THE SAME.
MORE WAR.
MORE IMMIGRATION AND MORE
TRADE DEAL.
THE G.O.P. ESTABLISHMENT AND
SOME OF THE DEMOCRATS, WELL,
THEY HEARD THE CALL TO WALL
STREET.
THEY DID NOT HEAR THE VOICES
OF MEN LIKE THIS.
>> MY FATHER IN THE '80s
LOST HIS JOB DUE TO IMPORTS
COMING IN TO THIS COUNTRY.
I WANT TO TELL YOU WHAT THAT
DOES TO A MAN WITH SIX KIDS IS
DEVASTATING.
I NEVER FORGOT LOOKING INTO
HIS EYES IN A HOUSEHOLD WHAT
IT DOES TO MY FAMILY.
YOU HEAR ABOUT IT BUT IT
IMPACTS YOU AND IT WILL NEVER
LEAVE YOU.
>> Laura: THAT SHOULD NEVER
LEAVE ANY OF US.
NOW DONALD TRUMP, THE ONLY
REPUBLICAN POLITICIAN SINCE
REAGAN WHO CAN FILL A STADIUM,
HE IS SUPPOSED TO LISTEN TO
THE SAME PEOPLE WHO HELPED GET
OUR COUNTRY INTO THE MESS THAT
HE HAS BEEN TRYING TO DIG US
OUT OF?
THE SAME PEOPLE BY THE WAY WHO
COULDN'T SEE ANY OF THIS
COMING.
AND STILL DO NOT SEE THE
THREAT CHINA POSES TO THE
UNITED STATES TO FREEDOM AND
YES, TO FREE MARKETS.
I THINK IT'S TIME FOR THE